♪
- CONGRATS.
THAT'S AWESOME.
- YEAH, DUDE,
IT'S REALLY EXCITING.
WE WANT IT TO BE
REAL ACTION-HEAVY,
SO WE GOT JASON STATHAM
AND JET LI INVOLVED ALREADY.
- THAT'S AWESOME.
- JUST TRYING TO GET
OTHER BIG NAMES INVOLVED.
- BIG NAMES.
WHAT UP?
I'M HERE.
- ADAM SOLD
HIS HIGH OCTANE PROJECT.
- REALLY?
- YEAH.
- YOU ARE A PRODUCER?
- YEAH, PRETTY MUCH.
- CAN I TALK TO YOU
REAL QUICK?
OUT HERE REAL QUICK.
WATCH THIS REAL QUICK.
- DOES HE ALWAYS LEAVE ROOMS
LIKE THAT?
- MAYBE, I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S HIS HOUSE.
- I SHOULD PROBABLY
GO OUT THERE.
- HONESTLY, DUDE, I JUST WANT
TO SAY CONGRA-JU-LATIONS.
- [laughs] THANKS, MAN.
- AND I DIDN'T MEAN
TO SAY "JEW" AS A--
- IT'S--NO, I GOT IT.
I DIDN'T TAKE IT OFFENSIVELY.
- YEAH, YEAH, 'CAUSE I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE JEWISH.
- WELL, I AM, SO IT'S NOT--
PRETTY EXCITED.
- YOU KNOW, HONESTLY,
YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN
ONE OF MY FAVORITE COMICS.
YOU'RE, LIKE,
AT A RICHARD PRYOR LEVEL FOR ME.
- WOW, THANKS, MAN.
- IT'S REALLY COOL THAT
BOTH OF OUR CAREERS ARE JUST...
[imitating airplane]
TAKING OFF LIKE...
- YEAH.
- PARALLEL FIGHTING JETS
SOARING
THROUGH THE DEEP, BLUE SKY.
[gasps]
WE'RE LIKE THE BLUE ANGELS.
OH, MY GOD,
WE ARE BLUE ANGELS!
SAY IT WITH ME RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE BLUE AN--
THIS IS A GOOD BONDING
EXPERIENCE FOR US.
- YEAH.
- WE ARE BLUE ANGELS.
SAY IT RIGHT NOW.
- NO, I'M GOOD.
- WE MIGHT AS WELL,
THOUGH, FOR FUN.
WE ARE...
both: BLUE ANGELS!
- HEY, ADAM,
I'LL SEE YOU IN THE SKY.
[imitating airplane]
I'M TAKING OFF!
- THERE YOU GO.
- HEY, DARE ME TO JUMP
DOWN THESE STAIRS RIGHT NOW?
- DEFINITELY SHOULDN'T DO THAT.
- SHOULD I JUMP OFF HERE?
- DON'T--NO, JUST--
- HEY, MAN,
YOU'RE A GREAT PRODUCER,
WORRYING ABOUT YOUR ACTORS.
I GET THAT.
TIME ME, I'LL RUN DOWN 'EM.
EXCUSE ME.
OHH!
ARE YOU NOT ENTERTAINED?
SUCKA!